the Disney Channel has a hidden secret
vault full of shows that were cancelled
before they ever even aired watch until
the end to find out which popular Disney
Channel original movie started out as a
TV show but was cancelled before it ever
saw the light of day forever boys
forever boys was a show about three
brothers who have been vampires since
the 50s after decades of hiding in the
shadows to keep their secrets they come
out into the light as a vampire boy band
it starred the members of the band
forever in your mind
Ricky Garcia Emory Kelly and Liam at
Ridge the members are forever in your
mind have worked with the Disney Channel
before they sing the theme song for best
friends whenever a few years back
forever boys was set to come out this
year but for some unknown reason did he
cancelled it before it aired they only
filmed the pilot episode Ricky said that
the pilot was so good and he really wish
people could watch it now but ultimately
the executives at Disney decided they
wanted to go younger with the channel
Liam added that they wouldn't be where
they are now without the show and even
though it was devastating at the time he
believes it's a blessing in disguise
growing up and down this Disney Channel
show titled growing up and down it is
about a brother and a sister who
accidentally transformed their parents
into teenagers when they rubbed a magic
Liam their parents become 14-year olds
who must attend high school with their
teenage kids Sydney and Ben's parents
were divorced before the transformation
as her 14 year old self then in Sydney's
mom Jackie tries to control her
daughter's life as a 40 year old stuck
in a 14 year olds existence their dad
Pete fits in rather well with the high
school crowd the show would have starred
Raini Rodriguez from austin and Ally as
well as Adam Irie goin from shake it up
and Noah sent Ennio from to all the boys
I've loved before there's very little
information as to why the show was
cancelled the pilot was set to come out
in 2014 but never saw the light of day
still a would be interesting to have
seen a pair of parents in teenage bodies
going to school with their teenage kids
fell over Quinn in 2011 a series named
Gulliver Quinn almost hit the Disney
Channel screen the show was about a 28
year old guy named Gulliver played by
Napoleon Dynamite's John header you know
that expression have you been living in
a cave well Gulliver had literally been
living in a
for most of his childhood life his
parents were animal researchers who hid
out in caves to study their subjects
since Gulliver spent his formative
school years in the wild he must attend
the seventh grade as a fully grown adult
it's the only way he can graduate but
socially he's still a preteen Gulliver
befriends a group of equally quirky
junior high school kids among the kids
was Sabrina carpenter before her Girl
Meets World days it also starred Sam
Adler and a wee little Joey Bragg who
knows why the show was canceled before
it got going maybe because it's a little
weird for a 28 year old man to be
hanging out with a bunch of seventh
graders yep that's probably it
Arwen a gay housebroken in addition to
the suite life on deck there was going
to be another spin-off of Suite Life of
Zack and Cody
instead of focusing on the boys this
show centered around the Tipton hotels
beloved resident engineer Arwen in the
spin-off Arwen left the Tipton hotel to
move in with her sister and help her
raise her three kids in a smart house
that sounds like the perfect place for
an engineer the show starred Bryan
Stepanek as our win of course but it
also starts samantha trope from Pretty
Little Liars Nia Peeples and Selena
Gomez they filmed the pilot episode in
2007 but Disney inevitably decided to
scrap production of the show it seems
like Disney Channel prefers shows that
center around kids rather than adults
shut well the show never aired there
still are some clips from the pilot
floating around out there
Madison High Madison High is another
Disney Channel show that flickered out
before it made it to the small screen
the school wanted to build an
unprecedented theater program where the
students would produce an original
theater piece based on their lives the
show incorporated song and dance as a
storytelling device similar to Disney's
High School Musical movies it would have
been the first time that they based an
original Disney Channel show off of a
Disney Channel original movie according
to the show's wiki peeps Gian Elias was
set to star in dog with a blog instead
and rumor had it that Disney was looking
to have shows that centered around whole
families rather than just high school
kids considering that the executive
producer of Jonah's LA and the director
of Camp brought to the Final Jam were
involved in the show it probably would
have been a
the odd cousins Todd Jay Greenwald who
created Wizards of Waverly Place and
wrote for Hannah Montana was working on
this potential Disney Channel show he
described it as a show about two cousins
who were total opposites one was a sunny
and bright SoCal cheerleader the other
one was an emo Northwestern grungy kid
from Portland the emo cousin was sent to
live in sunny Southern California with
her cheerleader cousin it was like a
modern-day Disney version of The Odd
Couple with a fish out of water element
the show was supposed to star
Aly & AJ to taka but they weren't
available for the gig he wound up
teaching the odd cousins right around
the time that high school musical was
blowing up eventually Todd went on to
create Wizards of Waverly Place and they
all lived happily ever after
still that would have been a really fun
show to watch zombies and cheerleaders
if you're thinking this concept sounds
like a wildly popular Disney Channel
original movie you'd be right this
Disney Channel pilot was in the works in
2011 just like the popular Disney
Channel Original Movie the show followed
the story of a high school kid named Ted
who was a zombie
I'm sad and yeah I'm a zombie the show
was going to be a musical just like the
movie the details surrounding the show's
cancellation are unclear but fans
believe that Disney wanted to focus on
making zombies the movie instead they
even moved three of the original cast
members from the zombies and
cheerleaders TV show and put them in the
movie project after seeing the
incredible success of Disney Channel
zombies it's obviously made the right
choice can you imagine what it would
have been like as an ongoing TV show
which of these cancelled Disney Channel
shows would you like to see tell us in
the comments if you're a Disney Channel
fan be sure to subscribe so you never
miss a video and give us a big thumbs up
if you want to see these cancelled
Disney Channel shows as much as we do
thanks for watching the theme catch you
next time
[Music]